>> IN ADDITION TO ALL THE OTHER
PROBLEMS THAT CALIFORNIA HAS,
HOUSING PRICES THERE ARE HIGHER
THAN ANY PLACE IN THE COUNTRY.
THE MEDIAN HOME PRICE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS NOW MORE
THAN 800,000-DOLLAR, THAT'S MORE
THAN DOUBLE THE NATIONWIDE
MEDIAN.
IN RECENT YEARS, BECAUSE THIS
REALLY IS A PROBLEM, LEADERS IN
CALIFORNIA PASSED DOZENS OF
BILLS THEY CLAIM WOULD FIX THE
PROBLEM.
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN, THE LAST
GUY, SIGNED 15 HOUSING BILLS
JUST IN 2017.
LAST YEAR GAVIN NEWSOM SIGNED 18
SEPARATE HOUSING BILLS.
DID THEY WORK?
NOT AT ALL.
THEY DID NOT WORK FOR THE PEOPLE
WHO LIVE IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT THEY WEREN'T INTENDED FOR
PEOPLE WHO WANTED TO BUY HOUSES
INSTEAD THOSE BILLS HAD ONE
PURPOSE:  DESTROYING SUBURBAN
HOMES AND REPLACING THEM WITH
LIFE DENSITY HOUSING.
REAL ESTATE DEVELOPERS MAKE MORE
MONEY WHEN SINGLE FAMILY HOMES
ARE LEVELED AND REPLACE REPLACED
WITH APARTMENT COMPLEXES,
OBVIOUSLY.
AND REAL ESTATE DEVELOPERS
HAPPEN TO BE MAJOR DONORS TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY OF CALIFORNIA,
AND IN PARTICULAR TO GAVIN
NEWSOM.
THE REAL ESTATE DEVELOP MARCUS
WAS ONE OF NEWSOM'S BIGGEST
DONORS IN THE RECENT RECALL
ELECTION.  THIS WEEK AFTER
SURVIVING THE RECALL,
TRAGICALLY, GAVIN NEWSOM
REWARDED THOSE REAL ESTATE
DEVELOPERS TH THE BIGGEST,
QUOTE, HOUSING BILL EVER.
NEWSOM JUST SIGNED A SERIES -F
BILLS, SB9 AND SB10, THAT WILL
ABOLISH THE SUBURBS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
THE STATE THAT INTEND-VENTED THE
SUBURBS.
THOSE BILLS WERE ENDORSED BY THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION, WHICH REPRESENTS,
QUOTE, INTEREST OF BUILDERS AND
DEVELOPERS OF HOUSING AND
COMMERCIAL PROJECTS.
THEY'RE ABOUT TO BE QUITE A FEW
NEW COMMERCIAL PROJECTS IN
CALIFORNIA'S SUBURBS.
AS THE NEW YORK TIMES PUT IT,
QUOTE, SB9 ESSENTIALLY ENDS
SINGLE FAMILY ZONING.
PROPERTY OWNERS NOW HAVE THE
STATE'S APPROVAL TO CONVERT ANY
SINGLE FAMILY HOME IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA INTO A 4-UNIT
APARTMENT COMPLEX.
HOW IS THIS IMPROVING ANYONE'S
LIFE?
IT WON'T.
IT MEANS DEMOLISHING HOMES TO
PUT UP RENTAL UNITS.  AT THE
BEHEST OF HIS DONORS GAVIN
NEWSOM IS TURNING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA INTO A SWAMP.
IT'S NOT JUST HAPPENING IN
CALIFORNIA.  RECENTLY OREGON
PASSED A STATEWIDE BAN ON SINGLE
FAMILY ZONING.  THIS IS INSANE.
CITIES LIKE MINNEAPOLIS AND
SACRAMENTO HAVE BEGUN TO TO
ALLOW MULTIFAMILY DWELLINGS ON
SINGLE FAMILY LOTS.
CROWDING A PROBLEM, ANYONE
THINK?
ONLY THE GOVERNMENT OF CHINA, BY
THE WAY, APPEARS TO BE DOING
ANYTHING TO RAVEN IN REAL ESTATE
DEVELOPERS.  HOUSING SHOULD BE
LIVING AND NOT FOR SPECULATION
SAID THE PRESIDENT OF CHINA.
WOO HATE TO QUOTE THE PRESIDENT
OF CHINA, BUT IN THIS CASE HE IS
RIGHT ONE OF THE LARGEST AND
MOST LEVERAGED REAL ESTATE
COMPANIES IN THE WORLD IS
COLLAPSING AND CHINA HAS GIVEN
THE INDICATION THEY'RE
INTERESTED BANE BAILING OUT EVER
GRANT.
IN THIS COUNTRY REAL ESTATE
COUNTRIES DON'T JUST GET
BAILOUTS, THEY GET GET TO WRITE
THE LAW, WRECK YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD.  AND AND IN MANY
PARTS OF AMERICA THEY WILL BE
ABLE TO DEMOLISH T